once my boyfriend was asleep so i wanted
to go [ __ ] my ex real quick so i drove
down to the gas station let him cry me
and then i came home to sneak into bed
my boyfriend woke up and then wanted to
and he started eating me out and told me
how good my puppy tastes and he's eating
my exes come out of me and i never told
him so as you ladies and gents saw
this lady um
was with her boyfriend uh ex called her
she met him at the gas station she had
to exit the gas station
he cried her as she said she went back
to her boyfriend her boyfriend ate her
out and said she tasted great
no what do we think of that video before
we even get into it it's bold
it's why
it's actually green
i mean apparently he didn't because she
tasted great
i mean unless she told him and just
admitted that from the story but i don't
think so
but i'm very confused as to why you meet
at the gas station
why are you [ __ ] there there's lights
everywhere is petrol
yeah that's right people you're thinking
you think you meet at like a motel right
like at least
surely you just go around his house yeah
yeah well i guess so maybe maybe he had
a girl too oh god maybe it was like
mutual that is i'm shaking that's like
you know she's not above it he's
probably not above it right so what do
you think
i mean i just think go on
i think maybe this stuff happens
more often than i said but you just
never know you know this is a very
specific situation
yeah but i've never heard it before so
so i have a question um have any of you
ever cheated no yeah no no
so no so
now have any of you ever witnessed a
friendship
no no
yes yes yes
no no okay
so you see like
that's a pretty
outrageous clip right but for me she was
bold enough
to go on to like a podcast and say that
type of stuff so
women like this right the reason why
this um episode is called broken women
broken society
women like this raise children
right eventually right how do you know
um if she went if she goes to have
children um
for me
for me this type of psychology
and the way in which is so easily um
it's so easy to cheat and be like
quote-unquote sexually liberated to the
point of i think to the detriment of
society
um
[Music]
what do you think if the women of this
society continue to go down this road
how do you think society is going to end
up
i don't think you can say like women i
can i think you can say that one person
yeah i was about to say it went viral
because it's not normalized like if it
was normalized everyone just said oh
yeah that's fine yeah like i don't think
anyone here was like oh yeah i did that
would you last week would you say by and
large women are getting more promiscuous
though than like 100 years ago yes but
like it's the whole like sexual
liberation
but it comes with the whole fact that
we've been like repressed for our
sexuality for so so long and so now it's
kind of but also kind of mostly
appreciated for sexuality and there's
this like distorted divide where we're
not allowed to be sexual but also we're
expected to be sexual
and so like sexual liberation is
essentially reclaiming the power back on
that so doing things like that but i
guess it's a bit distorted just because
it's such a a gray area
you know i feel like
what you said is like perfect
but i feel like this woman didn't do it
in the name of sexual liberation she's
just one random really weird person i
don't think she did it in the name of
this is for women this is for sexual
liberation this is for you know i think
she's just
don't you think sexual liberation has
led to women doing stuff like this
feeling more free to do it yeah i think
it's all it's probably always happened
it's just like
they're more vocal about it now and like
statistically like the generation before
us are actually a lot more sexually
sexually promiscuous than our generation
we're actually like no one's
can't swear no one's holding hands in
bed anymore like compared to
they're like no one's [ __ ]
yeah that's fine
but now it's like more accepted that you
just go online and like you can just go
viral for anything so you're going to
say the most out loud on this stuff like
she might not have even done that right
yeah she might have just said it i want
to be famous yeah but i don't know but
it's possible this kind of stuff has
happened i mean it's definitely happened
i would say at least once yeah so but to
both genders
oh yeah i mean it goes both ways but the
thing is that typically if you look at
the sexlessness stats of our generation
it's usually the men that are sexless
it's not the women
yeah one out of three men under 30 is a
virgin or hasn't had sex in the past
year okay so like usually when you look
at those stats like actually women are
having sex with more people and men are
having sex with less because it's a
smaller and smaller percentage of men
that are having sex with all the girls
yeah because women choose who assets so
yeah because like the more the more
girls sleep around like typically they
sleep up like they date up and so it
just becomes a smaller and smaller
percentage
do you think sexual liberation has
helped the western world or hindered it
in what way
um in the morals of the moral fabric of
society do you think it's helped or
hindered it i think there was always sex
but it was always far away from us so it
was like magazines tv
media and whatever but it's now normal
for just a normal person to be like
super sexy and it's not
you know but i think
i think it's helped i would say it
depends on what you're trying to
accomplish really i think we're still
working towards sexual liberation i feel
like there's still so many restrictions
around it that even when you are
sexually liberated you still have such a
backlash you still have so many people
um attacking you just because you can
have the freedom to do what you want it
doesn't mean you don't get the
repercussions of it and i think that's
still there so i don't think we're
really sexually liberated because we
still have that judgment on it yeah
repercussions are just like a natural
law of nature it's not yeah it's not
like people are saying
it's about judgment in it it's about
people judging obviously it's not a
great situation that's pretty messed up
but well in my opinion um
sorry i lost my train of thought
i think i think the difference between
this and then a woman just being
sexually liberated and shaggy she wants
is
there's
that you're lying to someone here and
it's it's not okay to do that to someone
and i think that's what is so
shocking like if she was just like oh
yeah my boyfriend lets me go sit with my
ex
in the gas station he's really kind
about that like and then he'll eat me
out into it then i'll be like yeah go
girl like you found someone who accepts
what you're into
like
so i agree with that but also like you
you don't do that to people that's awful
and then you brag about it like what but
then isn't that what sexual liberation
is isn't it about being able to have sex
and be free and tell people look i'm
allowed to have sex i can do what i want
as a woman i can have sex with who i
want the way i want if it's open and
honest and if both people are in on it
but in like that situation it seemed
like the guy wasn't in on it so in that
case like yeah don't you think sexual
liberation hurts women though in the end
in what sense
so like women that sleep with more
people have higher rates of depression
they're more likely to be on
anti-depression drugs and drugs and the
more people they sleep with the less
likely they are to have a happy marriage
so i think that comes sorry and um so
basically like when you the more women
are sleeping around it's like a smaller
percentage of men get to have sex with
all the girls
and so it's like you're basically a side
chick
no because you you get a lot of data
from like dating apps yeah so you can
really see where
people are sleeping with i would i would
say that that boom and kind of like
sexuality especially in like women is is
more kind of like a time thing where we
haven't really been able to be that open
with our sexuality and that free with
our sexuality especially like as soon as
like 30 years ago there were still so
many restrictions on that so many
expectations and we're only now breaking
past that expectations where it has to
go so much further the other way before
it can be brought back a little bit and
i think it's people chasing that because
they think that's what's going to bring
them that fulfillment but just because
they don't know they haven't explored
that they haven't had the opportunity to
explore that before so how much time do
you think needs to pass because birth
control was developed in the 70s um in
the u.s at least that's when roe versus
wade was passed which i know was
overturned now
but but that's still a lot of time like
that's longer than i've been alive yeah
like so my whole life like we've been
liberated you know i think when it's not
like a systematic thing so like back in
the day the further back you go the more
sort of worse it is so that women have
never been sort of integrated into
society in a way of like
i don't know i lost my jacket
do you mean in the sense that they
weren't able to vote
yeah yeah yeah so
i think what i'm trying to say is um
before it was so bad now it's like okay
and we need to get it's like
perfect and i think even if there's like
kind of legal restrictions that have
been removed there's still a lot of
conservative spaces where sexuality
isn't really free and it still affects
this generation like our parents
generation who like for example my
parents are catholic or come from
catholic backgrounds and there's a very
conservative mindset there where sex
wasn't talked about i wasn't even
talking about my period
when i was a kid so even though like
legally and kind of in the like social
world yes that still were past that